it is the man who goes looking not the
woman no no it's better to be single and
odd than married and miserable marry a
girl and give her to the mother as a
servant in the house no your wife is not
your mother's servant it is the man who
goes looking not the
woman uh let's pray
first Our Father in heaven we thank you
for the knowledge you've given to us in
your word we thank you there God for the
spirit that makes the word clear to us
us as we try to answer these questions
speak directly through me I pray and
through my brother that your people may
gain an understanding of what you would
have them to do and how you would have
them to live here this humble prayer
father in Jesus name I pray amen how do
you know that you're ready to enter into
a
relationship and how do you know what
are the qualities that a woman or a man
should be looking for for as a Christian
Adventists in Genesis 2 reading from
verse 21 the Bible says and the Lord God
caused the Deep Sleep to fall upon Adam
and he
slept and he took one of his ribs and
closed up the flesh instead thereof and
the rib which the Lord God had taken
from man made he a woman and brought her
unto the
man we have a man and a woman so we have
two mature people we do not have a boy
and a girl as is popular in this present
age we have a man and a woman
presupposing emotional maturity to a
certain level the requirements for
relationship one which is almost never
considered is that what God wants for
you let me explain why Jesus was not
married
Paul was not married Daniel was not
married and God told Jeremiah do not
marry and do not have children Jeremiah
16 so we mustn't assume everyone has to
enter into a relationship and so
requirement one is this what God wants
from me not what Society expects of
me society says 178 have a relationship
20 get married by 25 you have seven
children that may not be God's will for
you and this is very serious we enter
into situations into which God has not
sent
us and so requirement one God is it your
will for me that I enter into a
relationship question two with
whom with whom the requirements for the
man very general he must must be a man
not a
boy one have some means of
support are you with me willing to leave
his
family why do I stress that I have
counseled many
women who complain the husband wants the
wife to be a house servant for the
mother the
mother marry a girl and give her to the
mother as a servant in that house no
your wife is not your mother's
servant and so be willing to leave your
father and your mother not abandon leave
we see this principle in nature where
after certain age animals are driven
out and so he must be willing to
leave let me say something that's not in
question it is the man who goes looking
not the woman
the Bible doesn't say therefore shall a
woman leave her father and mother and cl
no therefore shall a man leave he is the
one who
searches are you with me all right not
the woman don't go looking for man let a
man find you as a daughter of
God emotional man emotionally
immature uh some form of income some
place to put the woman are you following
me but above all are a relationship with
God because that man will be a priest
not a perfect priest but a priest are
you following me don't marry a man
spiritually weaker than
you where you have to lead him to the
altar that's not God's will marry
someone spiritually stronger than you a
man in that position that he may take
the lead as the priest of the home for
the woman woman who loves to be
home and not in the mall 24 hours a day
she loves to be home her home is her
Palace and she is the queen of that
house of course number one she has a
relationship with God Amen Now ladies
who are considering marriage men who are
considering marriage read proverbs 31
10-31 there is no other document on
earth that is Des cribes more clearly
what a desirable woman is like she's not
a woman who cannot think she's
intelligent she's assertive she can run
a business she she knows how to take
care of the home and outside the home
she's a leader in her own right she's
not a
puppet or a
robot you read about Abigail in the
Bible how she saved her husband's life
when David was coming to kill him
Abigail very intelligent woman El talks
about her and so number one a
relationship with God for both mature
now keep this in mind women tend to
mature sooner than
men and so a 20-year-old lady may be
more mature than a 20-year-old man no
wonder the general uh advice is let the
man be older than the woman are you with
me nobody said amen amen was Adam older
than Eve
was Adam older than Eve yes now that's
not to say if you're 25 and a man you
cannot marry a woman who's 26 I'm not
saying that I'm simply saying the
general principle is the man is older
than a woman another good biological
reason for that is a man can father
children when he's 70 or 75 a woman
cannot do
that and so it makes biological sense to
have the woman younger particularly if
children are part of your future and let
God decide if children must be part of
your
future okay spiritual growth emotional
maturity the man must have a source of
income the woman can do the man must
have some place to put his wife and the
man must be willing to defend his
wife if the family attacks
her let me tell you why I this is what
I've encountered in my counseling
men defend their mothers against their
wives you can't do
that the closest connection on Earth is
not son and mother or son and father it
is what husband and wife you must defend
your wife against everyone except God
you must defend your wife against
everyone except God allow your family to
make your wife miserable if your mother
visits your mother is a guest
he doesn't run around the house trying
to take over uhuh she's a guest your
wife is in charge of that
house I'm sure you all get along but I
thought I'd throw that
out all right that's all I can say on
that by the way those of you considering
relationships read messages to young
people
please read the Adventist home and for
those of you Desiring children read
child
guidance please I'll give you one more
book read letters to young lovers so
therefore for those of you quing
messages to young people letters to
young lovers for those of you who
recently married or just on the verge of
marriage Advent is home and when
children are part of your Thinking Child
Guidance one more
thing and please keep a straight face I
don't want to see who's guilty
marry within your
religion amen I have a few amens on this
side nothing on the
oh let me say it again by let me say it
this way in Genesis chapter 6 the
chapter where we're introduced to the
flood and why God will send the flood
the Bible says and it came to pass when
men began to multiply on the face of the
Earth and daughters were born unto them
that the sons of God saw the daughters
of men that they were fair and they took
them wives of all which they chose the
only identified offense against God in
Genesis 6 now it does say the Earth was
filled with violence it does say that
doesn't identify but the only clearly
identified
offense is children of God marrying
children of the
world and I'll leave it right there next
question okay next question this is a
related question but uh it belongs to
someone who is married mhm if I get
married to a nonbeliever did I sin
that's the first question all right
we'll take it piece by
piece do you have your Bibles with you
yes I'll miss this side when I leave
second Corinthians 6 2 Corinthians
6 now keep in mind truth is not always
Pleasant are you with me all
right you have 2 Corinthians 6 let's
read verse
14 be not unequally alt together with
unbelievers for what Fellowship hath
righteousness with unrighteousness or
what communion hath light with Darkness
now when Paul says what Fellowship ha
righteousness with unrighteousness or
what communion has light with Darkness
he's quoting from Genesis 1 from verse3
and God said let there be light and
there was light and God saw the light
that it was good and God divided the
light from the
darkness and Paul uses that creation
event to make a spiritual point when you
marry outside of your religion you
displease God
yes
mhm remember
Samson Samson saw Philistine woman he
came to the parents get her for me the
parents said Samson can't you find an
Israelite
woman Samson said she pleases me
well God says they will take you from
me not you will bring them to me they
will take you from me and so we have to
be very careful one of the top five
reasons for marital stress is difference
in religion Plus Finance and
communication difference in
religion there's a person I
know no very well married outside the
church and gradually
left the
church I've known more than one person
in that way gradually left the church in
attempt to please the
man mhm I have to please my husband no
you have to please God first
marriage cannot change that God always
remains first regardless of
circumstances it doesn't mean the
unbeliever is bad it simply means a
square peg does not fit a round hole
that's all not the person is bad a
square peg must fit a square hole next
question next question is it advisable
to Mary hold on hold on yes
huh is is a sin if it displeases God it
is MHM I just wanted to be nice okay is
it advisable to Mary a divorced
nonbeliever and Bel or believer men is
it what is it advisable to marry a
divorced believer or non-believer
man there's nothing wrong with a
divorced
person the first question is is it God's
will for me to unite with this person
because there's some divorced people who
are absolutely innocent are you
following me they have been divorced
they're innocent and the teaching of
this church is the innocent person can
remarry that's the teaching of this
church so being divorced is not a strike
against your suitability for marriage
the question is has God chosen this
person for me whether the person is
divorced or not is this God's Will and
God is willing to tell you his will as
for the unbeliever the answer is no
okay the next question is uh if you're
hold on hold
on there is no boyfriend evangelism in
the
Bible uh-uh there's no girlfriend
evangelism God told the Israelites do
not intermarry with the Nations around
you that's what he told them plain and
straight MH obeying God is not always
easy because our minds are different
from God's mind but in the long run it's
the safest way to
live always ask yourself what are the
consequences in the long
run okay if your unbelieving partner
decided to
live and look and live with another
woman is the
wife can file divorce or analment to
have a certificate of divorce and she
can marry again
now if I knew these questions were of
this nature I would not have agreed stay
in my room now Customs very I understand
in the Philippines you can't divorce is
that true no we you can't divorce all
right analment only well whether the
Philippines or Malaysia or wherever the
Bible is the Bible and the sday
Adventist Church has positions it is
taken based on scripture and counsel
from Ellen White if an unbeliever
leaving
partner decides to leave you there's
very little you can do are you with me
leaving you is not
divorce are you following me that may be
separation separation does not free you
to
remarry now if the person who leaves you
gets involved with someone else and
commits adultery breaks the marriage
contact you are free to marry
but don't go hoping the person does that
are you following me don't do that
because God is a god of
reconciliation but if the person
believer or Not by the way breaks the
marriage vows you the innocent party are
free to marry the guilty person must
remain
unmarried that's the position of this
church the guilty person cannot well
should not because frequently they do
should should not
remarry let me tell you something
marriage is Serious
Business it is not a social
custom it's so it's serious if you're
not 100% sure stay out of
it but that's what I mean don't get
married yes if you're not serious you
see marriage is once you're
in that's it the door is shut you can't
get
out if she ceases to cook for you you
can't leave if she get hits by a bus and
loses her beauty you cannot
leave it is
serious but people marry because it's
accustomed to do everybody's marrying
Let Me Marry too so I don't look odd no
no it's better to be single and odd than
married and
miserable all right okay the next
question is is it okay for church
leaders to be a witness or Guardian in
an unequally yoke marriage will they be
held accountable
accountable you're really trying to get
me into
trouble if the church is against mixed
marriages how can the church authorize a
minister to officiate at a mixed
marriage
how the the church is officially against
mixed
marriages is that clear as
day the Seventh Day Adventist Church is
against mixed
marriages what oh an equally same thing
yes now an Adventist Minister May marry
a Catholic and a
Baptist because prophetically they're
the same thing ah you don't understand
what I'm trying to say prophetically
they the same
thing are you following me he may marry
a Pentecostal and uh
whomever not an Adventist and a
non-adventist
what of course they held
accountable if my sister married a non
Adventist I would not go to the
wedding okay next
question the men and the woman lived as
a couple yes both are separated uh-huh
can they be
baptized they live together yes but
they're not married yeah they live
together and they're not married they're
not married but they live as a couple no
no no no no they can't do
that they can't do that you live
together with your spouse are you
following
me nobody said amen amen
this whole church needs to be re
baptized nobody said amen you live with
your spouse do not allow the standards
of the world to dictate the behavior of
the church we must teach the world not
the world teach the church you live with
your wife or your husband and if he's
not your husband you live in paranak and
he may live in some other place
sagon but not in the same house are you
following
me
M why you asking question well I
shouldn't ask you that go ahead